turquía ha cerrado hasta nuevo aviso la
ruta migratoria que lleva desde el país
anatolio hacia bielorrusia para entrar
luego a polonia y a la unión europea así
lo han firmado este mismo viernes por la
mañana la dirección general de tráfico
civil turca que ha anunciado que los
ciudadanos de yemen siria e irak tendrán
a partir de hoy mismo la venta y la el
embarque a aviones hacia minsk
completamente prohibidas sólo podrán
hacerlo aquellos que tengan pasaporte
diplomático de estos tres países esto no
significará sin embargo que la crisis
migratoria en la frontera de polonia
termine todo lo contario aunque los
vuelos desde estambul us también serán
la mayoría de los que llegaban con
refugiados cargados de refugiados e
inmigrantes eso no significa que sean
los únicos vuelos que llegan hasta
bielorrusia también lo están haciendo
decenas semanalmente de aviones
procedentes de damasco
dubai
bagdad y otras capitales de oriente
medio esta ha sido la forma de prohibir
los vuelos a hasta minsk por de parte de
unas nacionales la forma de responder de
turquía a las acusaciones de la umh
europea y de polonia de permitir y ser
en convivencia con los gobiernos de
moscú y minsk para crear esta crisis de
refugiados en la frontera europea el
gobierno turco lo niega rotundamente
asegura no tener nada que ver con esta
crisis migratoria que está siendo muy
grave para las fronteras este es de la
unión europea